I've been working on issues of poverty for more than 20 years...
...and so, it's ironic that the problem and question that I most grapple with is how you actually define poverty.
What does it mean?
So often we look at dollar terms,...
...people making less than a dollar, or two, or three a day...
...and yet, the complexity of poverty really has to look at income as only one variable,...
...because really, it's a condition about choice, and the lack of freedom.
And I had an experience that really deepened and elucidated for me the understanding that I have.
It was in Kenya and I wanna share it with you.
I was with my friend Susan Meiselas, the photographer, in the Mathare Valley slums.
Now, Mathare Valley is one of the oldest slums in Africa.
It's about three miles out of Nairobi...
...and it's a mile long, and about two-tenths of a mile wide,...
...where over half a million people live crammed in these little tin shacks.
Generation after generation, renting them, often eight or ten people to a room,...
...and it's known for prostitution, violence, drugs.
A hard place to grow up.
And when we were walking through the narrow alleys,...
...it was literally impossible not to step in the raw sewage and the garbage alongside the little homes.
But at the same time, it was also impossible not to see the human vitality,...
...the aspiration, and the ambition of the people who live there.
Women washing their babies, washing their clothes, hanging them out to dry.
I met this woman, Mama Rose, who has rented that little tin shack for 32 years,...
...where she lives with her seven children.
Four sleep in one twin bed, and three sleep on the mud and linoleum floor,...
...and she keeps them all in school by selling water from that kiosk,...
...and selling soap and bread from the little store inside.
It was also the day after the inauguration...
...and I was reminded how Mathare is still connected to the globe.
And I would see kids on the street corners, and they'd say, "Obama, he's our brother!"
And I'd say, "Well, Obama's my brother, so that makes you my brother too."
And they would look quizzically, and then be like, "High five!"
And it was here that I met Jane.
I was struck immediately by the kindness and the gentleness in her face,...
...and I asked her to tell me her story.
She started off by telling me her dream.
She said, "I had two."
"My first dream was to be a doctor..."
"...and the second was to marry a good man who would stay with me and my family,..."
"...because my mother was a single mom,..."
"...and couldn't afford to pay for school fees."
"So, I had to give up the first dream, and I focused on the second."
She got married when she was 18, had a baby right away.
And when she turned 20, found herself pregnant with a second child,...
...her mom died, and her husband left her, married another woman.
So, she was again in Mathare with no income, no skill set, no money,...
...and so she ultimately turned to prostitution.
It wasn't organized in the way we often think of it.
She would go into the city at night with about 20 girls,...
...look for work, and sometimes come back with a few shillings, or sometimes with nothing.
And she said, "You know, the poverty wasn't so bad."
"It was the humiliation and the embarrassment of it all."